be careful these things are real so
don't think that's the key don't let it
think go for it I'm Sam I'm Eric and we
make up the YouTube channel so crispy
media today we're just discussing a cool
collaboration video and you with portal
digital I'm gonna be making a cool
360-degree video Eric has never ridden
the hoverboard before and I cannot wait
to try to get him on one and see what
happens yeah
step on in and down
think about balancing just like a
bicycle just relax
your left you got plenty of all around
you can gently put pressure forward on
your right foot okay so you something
you gotta do circles cheese bread five
everybody to have it taste this is a
breeze Lisbon aged about six weeks
packed it away in its wrapper about a
month ago doesn't smell bad maybe I
should try it before everybody
potentially hurts themselves
looks like creamy breathe so a little
salty pesum tell me what you think
Carmichael anybody would like to try
holy goes homemade Bree I asked them
that over here right
good hmm okay that's really salty you
put salt in the Rhine to keep the wrong
type smoking droid and I read that
didn't really matter how much you put on
just as long as it was coated in salt so
that's why there's too much salt but you
don't find out until a month and a half
after the fact okay so now I can adjust
see what you think Nick really that's
good I don't know Niko I think you might
have a unique little spin on Brady here
I named this variation Mike breva in
honor of Mykelti maker this is such a
weird camera that's trying to wrap my
head around how we should use this it
can't eat a camera yet we're not quite
so far enough to futures I can eat a
camera just import of the footage it's
very flat right now what that means it's
very low contrast and the color is very
D saturated the reason for that is it
actually gives you more room to push
things around when you're color grading
we have filters you can apply to this
that will automatically make it look
vibrant and punchy we have a filter
called film conversion to get it online
some people went out and did some
studies of film and how they interact
with colors and they made profiles for a
bunch of various consumer cameras and
professional cameras to emulate that
look of film so it's a quick and easy
way just click your fingers and put a
nice film color profile and put it we're
gonna see oh look
Oh who's black and white make it seem
like in the skylights in the flat
version you have one working on the
highlight square we need a punchy amps
it up a little bit
not too much a little blue so you tweet
the it TWiki whitebalance for example to
go from blue to cool to warm to adjust
to your life immature you don't really
need the footage to be raw because don't
convert plugin is smart enough to kind
of tint the colors correctly you're
handsome devil my brother Jim McKeen
goofy how's the exposure up a little bit
so do we use this camera for the roll
off my house teasing stop yeah just
clipped away always that mom does too
yeah most people I could don't care
about that I realize I might care about
that but vast majority people don't care
the detail of shadows is nice usually
don't get a lot of radiation in shadows
like that and that's that's where
compression would kind of kill some that
detail nice it's probably a good be camp
now I'm taking on like a gimbal so the
camera is a fine game bollocks all day
like we'd never take it off we take to
the studio and just leave it on the
gimbal alright
see if you did a nice boy like why can't
render more like Peter huh he pulls off
the camera a new video
oh is that making the video everything
that films goes onto the internet
everything if I'm going to stand by my
future predictions at all I need to use
this camera some more all I know is that
cheese has made out of mold it's been on
me all day Phil made mold
and
I'm just actually pretty good next Jesus
backed us coming out plus salt ticker
cheese your shoes - did you get those on
camera yet according to a year listen
man give me the camera question for you
guys
does Nick look like if the Browns worn
leather shoes with the cinched pants is
Nick a hipster or not let us know if you
would like a Twitter poll on what
determines someone to be a hipster or
Harley drivers same criteria fits both
Wow listen just because you're referring
to three-quarter helmet wearing
Sportster drivers doesn't mean that all
Harley drivers are hipsters